this thing is so complicated
it's just
according to tesla tesla cars are
developed with the highest standards of
safety in every aspect including
security now i'm not saying i didn't
believe them but i did want to find out
for myself so i did a little digging and
when i tell you that it's impossible to
steal a tesla you better believe me
because i'm about to tell you why stay
tuned a real life scenario i stumbled
upon some unlucky car thieves who tried
to do the impossible all the way in
australia two thieves stole annabelle's
tesla unfortunately for them before they
could even finish their break-in her
tesla app had already alerted her as
soon as she found out that her car was
in motion she followed the gps locator
with her friend and alerted the police
these particular car thieves left me
stunned because what happened next
couldn't have been predicted by anyone
not only did they abandon the car when
annabelle found them but they left their
toolbox and one of their driver's
licenses in her car for all her bravery
and of course tesla's features annabelle
was able to recover her car and the
thieves were apprehended soon after the
incident annabelle's app is just one of
the cool security features that comes
with the tesla let's take a look at the
rest of the tesla security features how
they work and how they make it
impossible for thieves to steal a tesla
what all security features are there in
a tesla the first security feature is a
good old tried and tested security alarm
the tesla alarm will sound and external
lights will flash if a locked door is
open without a valid key if you're like
me you're probably wondering what's so
special about the tesla security alarm
well it seems to work just like other
security alarms except for the fact that
the settings can be adjusted to enable
the alarm one minute after all
passengers exit the doors are locked and
a recognized key is no longer detected
by the car one more fun fact is that it
can be stopped using the key fob key
card or the tesla app looks like that
app is very handy then there is the
cabin camera every tesla model produced
in 2021 or later has one the camera is
located above the rear view mirror it is
equipped with tesla's vision software
and it is mainly there to determine
driver inattentiveness and provide
audible alerts to remind the driver to
keep their eyes on the road when
autopilot is engaged however it has a
security benefit as well it can record
everything that is happening inside your
car and relay it to your app if you have
enabled data sharing unfortunately it is
not yet smart enough to recognize a car
thief and automatically call the police
for you but it is a great tool to aid
with their investigation if your car was
indeed stolen the next security feature
is the pin to drive feature as the name
suggests it means that tesla owners can
set four digit verification codes that
must be entered before the car is driven
talk about extra security but at least
it's a four digit pin and not a long
password because i know i would forget
mine speaking of if you forget your pin
or want to disable pin to drive simply
go back to the setting on the
touchscreen tap the link to enter your
tesla login credentials and follow the
on-screen prompts this is a cool feature
but i'm not sure how many people would
have actually activated this feature on
the teslas but in any case pin to drive
seems like the feature that would have
stopped annabelle's car thieves before
they got any further the next feature is
by far the most recognizable tesla
security feature sentry mode sentry mode
monitors any suspicious activities
around a tesla when it's parked and
locked in certain locations when this
feature detects suspicious motion it
reacts depending on the severity of the
threat if the threat detected is
significant the cameras begin to record
and the alarm system is activated on top
of that the tesla app receives an alert
about the incident that occurred this
feature can be enabled in the settings
and on the tesla app like all the others
but unlike the others it can also be
enabled via voice command the upside is
that unless the vehicle is at a
supercharger sentry mode will remain
active until it is at or below 20
battery and like everything else that
happens to a tesla the tesla app sends a
notification if sentry mode is disabled
due to a low battery apart from that
sentry mode will also not record if the
dash cam is not properly installed and
equipped with a usb drive the latest
tesla models have added a live camera
option with this feature this allows for
the car's surroundings to be viewed
remotely to confirm it if it's safe to
return to it through the tesla app the
car can honk flash and allow the driver
to talk through the speakers if the need
arises as helpful as sentry mode is
tesla has always made it clear that it
is designed to add another layer of
protection to the car but it will not
prevent a thief from breaking into your
car but they gotta be really stupid to
do that with all the information that's
been collected on them while they're
breaking into the car another security
feature is the require manual entry
feature because all tesla cars have the
option to automatically unlock when
approached with the key by disabling
that feature the tesla will require a
key for entry making it harder for those
who may have ill intentions the final
tesla security feature is the intrusion
sensors feature while the standard
security system comes fitted on every
tesla the enhanced anti-theft system
provides an additional layer of
protection against certain braking
scenarios for the model s or model x
this system adds intrusion sensors
inside the rear view mirror and is
available on the tesla online store as
an accessory when the sensor is used it
will intermittently pulse ultrasonic
waves throughout the cabin it would
trigger the alarm if the signal is
disturbed by either an intrusion or
significant movement within the car with
all these layers you really have to
admire tesla's commitment to securing
their clients cars because if there's
one thing we do know about car thieves
is that they get spooked quite easily by
alarms or other strange security
features and the teslas have got those
in spades steps to start the car but
let's imagine for a second that our
thief has actually managed to get past
all those layers of security what then
if you thought that he or she would
catch a break from tesla then you
thought wrong starting a tesla has to be
a secret security measure in itself
because the required steps are unique to
their cars with the tesla model s the
instrument panel and touchscreen power
on as it is open so you can operate all
controls to shift press the brake pedal
and swipe up for drive or down for
reverse on the touchscreen's drive mode
strip if auto shift out of park is
enabled the car automatically selects
drive or reverse based on inputs from
various sensors if pin to drive is
enabled a valid pin must be entered on
the touchscreen before you can drive it
after all of that is done you still need
to know where to place your key card for
your tesla to finally start moving now
that's a complicated system to start a
car because of all these heaps of
features in the us it is estimated that
the tesla model s and model x are nearly
90 percent less likely to be stolen
probably because tesla has made it an
impossible task more good news is that
from 2011 to 2018 out of 115 track tesla
thefts 112 were recovered thanks to the
extensive security system and gps
facilities every time a car was stolen
tesla owners have just been able to
point the police to the thieves location
using their app just as annabelle did in
the story i shared earlier in the video
i think that is any car thief's worst
nightmare to be caught because the car
they stole told on them this is all
great for tesla and tesla owners and i
will be the first to admit that the
stolen tesla recovery rate is a glorious
example of the proof is in the pudding
and just that they might know what they
are doing over there at tesla however
even with all those security measures in
place is it really impossible to steal a
tesla are there any chinks in the armor
now before you rush out to order your
own tesla or if you are still
daydreaming about one there is a
particular vulnerability about the car
that you might need to be aware of this
[ __ ] in tesla's armor was identified by
a manchester-based cyber security
company called the ncc group the cyber
security company conducted rigorous
tests on tesla vehicles their results
showed that the model 3 and model y
vehicles are at risk from a
vulnerability in their bluetooth power
technology which can allow thieves to
unlock a tesla from up to 25 meters away
right now the car is locked the phone is
far away at the opposite end of the
office and my relay is not active so i
try unlocking the car see it doesn't let
me
however
once i start the relay
and it just takes a moment to get going
now i can approach the car
and lets me unlock
and not only this with the same attack i
can now start the car and drive it away
this is a major concern because tesla's
are only supposed to unlock if the
owner's mobile phone is within one meter
of the vehicle but a radio tool can
capture the bluetooth low energy or ble
signal from an owner's phone and
re-broadcast it to their car giving the
illusion that the owner is close by well
tesla it looks like you have some
homework so the answer to the question
is it impossible to steal a tesla is no
but it is pretty damn hard to get away
with stealing one that's for sure to get
this reputation as a car that is
impossible to steal security is clearly
one area that tesla can't afford to not
act on because that is part of their
appeal if i were them i'd gather the
best hackers to figure out all existing
vulnerabilities and then come up with
counter measures for each of the
identified vulnerabilities what about
you what do you think are tesla's
security features as good as they are
made out to be and should we now start
referring to stealing a tesla as mission
impossible let me know in the comment
section below if you enjoyed this video
hit the subscribe button and continue
watching by clicking on one of the cards
on your screen see you at the next one